okay now this is the comeback oh c9 c9  c9  i uh didn't see that before i made my  opening few moves this is changed c9s  okay shut up  that's great that's a great job actually  too advanced to advanced that's too  complicated for for chat no it's it's  not it's just not very good okay uh  and speaking of not good i don't think  my position is too good now oh i can't  even  i can go e for now  but it's no good probably  d5 doesn't work  not to take  let's take this one as well  position is  less than ideal okay if he exchanges  queens then  probably  i'm probably doing okay  oh he went for this one  okay five bishop of six  oh  little trick  getting too short of time here  push push push  [Music]  okay 95  take it  oh this money could  take you're even faster than nine good  job  yeah i was down  10 seconds with the worst position but  then i came back he's played more games  than you because